on
stage in workshops this is
Megan and in TV and film puppetry is an
art form known for entertaining but it's
also a platform for social and political
commentary fusing tradition with
technology welcome hello hello
hello to the enchanting world of
puppetry look at that Focus out of focus
on Lake Ontario is a magical shop called
puppet Island tucked away from the
hustle and bustle of downtown Toronto is
where you'll find Jamie Shannon I make
puppets and Puppeteer and make
television shows and I'm very lucky to
have done it my entire a career yeah
this is Mona this is like probably my
most famous character Jam's puppets have
graced well-known Children's shows from
nanan to the teen staple Mr mey you know
that teen um in Return Of The Moth Man
what's the definition of puppetry to e h
I guess bringing the inanimate to life
you get to design right from the
beginning and then you give it a
personality Spellbound by the charm of
puppetry good morning we couldn't resist
the urge to create our own performance
we have a special guest joining us Mark
the
shark uh oh thank you blah it's uh is it
thing
on but beneath the playful veneer lies a
deeper motive for the award-winning
Puppeteer you mentioned that you feel
lucky to have been able to do it for so
long what is it that keeps you going it
has influence it's you know it's what
people watch for entertainment I still
think puppets can save the world I
always was I was always motivated by
saving the world with puppets happy
people to you and Jamie isn't the only
one in the heart of Atlanta's vibrant
Arts District is North America's largest
nonprofit dedicated to
[Music]
puppetry the center for puppetry Arts
Blends education a museum and
performance all Under One Roof where you
can visit with old friends like Kermit
Gonzo and Big Bird and learn about the
history and future of the art form
Kelsey Fritz is the museum Director
people are always shocked when they're
like oh didn't realize the puppetry
could be so cool for adults too um but
it really is through puppetry you can
you can express things it might be hard
to express if it was done through actors
what are you see puppetry in its various
forms dates back thousands of years and
has been used around the globe
theatrically for ceremonies and for
social activism the center has the
largest Jim Henson collection in the
world with some of his groundbreaking
Productions The Muppet Show Fraggle Rock
and Sesame Street he really cared about
the puppetry Community as a whole both
um domestically and internationally so
in addition to being known for film and
television he also did a lot to support
puppeteers um and performers from all
over the world Hensen was a Visionary he
made characters household names as he
educated children and he showed adults
that puppetry could tackle serious
subject matter so JoJo do you recall
seeing one of these before he also
embraced technology helping to redefine
the way puppets are made and used for TV
and
film and this is the main puppet
building shop here at the center for
puppet arts in this Workshop puppets
transform from wood Fabric and string
into mesmerizing
characters Jason Hines has been the
Cent's resident puppet builder for more
than 20 years we don't specialize in any
one type of puppet so it really depends
on what type of show we're doing there's
some shows like that are all wooden
shows there are other shows that are all
fabric sometimes we do a lot of
sculpting clay and molding and casting
so there's a lot of skills that go into
it so we have a whole bunch of hand
tools here creating a puppet can be a
slow process but thanks to technology
like computer modeling and 3D printing
it's become more efficient pull them off
of the print bed you can see we have two
of the hands I've used it for a lot of
things I I've mostly used it for
mechanisms because you can get really
precise these are two of the mechanical
pieces that I made for a puppet
mechanism and this took about a day but
this is one that I was able to print
just a few
hours puppetry is having a moment from
Broadway hits to films like warhorse
Star Wars and the Little Mermaid puppets
are taking Center Stage it's really
difficult to turn on TV and not see
puppets on commercials shows movies have
puppets in it um there's so many big
stage shows right now that have puppets
in it I don't see how anyone could think
that it's a dying art form cuz puppets
are everywhere
what's up and that's where Raymond Carr
injects the traditional art form with a
modern cinematic Edge today he operates
from his atlanta-based studio so these
are some of the puppets that were used
in um an exhibit that featured my uh
short films this master Puppeteer is
known around the world for his daring
work in science fiction and horror for a
more grown-up audience I find myself put
pushing to blur those lines and also not
to be pigeon hold to be one or the other
because I love children's television but
I also am an adult and I like telling
stories that are relevant to me as an
adult I'd like to welcome you to futopia
Raymond's work can be found in popular
shows from Doom
Patrol to Atlanta rewriting what
traditional puppetry is and looks
like puppetry with mature themes and
conversations I almost didn't recognize
you with that blood everywhere so this
is a miniature ship that we built for
our film Joy
writers these two hand wheels
controlling the rotation of the
spaceship my last film that I made was a
film called Joy
riters the conversation in the short is
whether or not you use your abilities to
help your community around you or
whether or not you have any obligation
to that at all so it was comedic and it
was flashy but it also was saying
something and then this one is a
practice puppet and when he started in
the '90s he only knew of two other black
puppeteers because there's so few of us
traditionally in those spaces you often
times become the the sounding board and
the lead person talking about everything
that that is relevant to the black
community it can be kind of daunting but
I feel it as an educational opportunity
this is a poster from our film hitor
Raymond's work showcases puppetry as a
versatile and Powerful art form that
continues to evolve I can't get out
setting the stage for New Heights and
future
puppeteers this is getting
[Music]
weird it's an exciting morning at creev
Hall Elementary School in Nashville
Tennessee good morning I am Miss Megan
and I am a puppeteer on Sesame Street
have you all ever watch Sesame
Street yeah special guest Megan pus is
set to amaze the dozens of wide-eyed
kindergarteners with her puppetry Talent
June buug look at all these friends we
have y'all going to be my friends what
these young minds don't know is that she
isn't just a puppeteer but a
trailblazing artist Megan is Sesame
Street's first full-time black female
Puppeteer I still don't know what I want
to do yet alongside iconic puppets like
big bird Elmo and Cookie Monster Megan's
own character 6-year-old Gabrielle also
calls Sesame Street home one of my
favorite pictures is from my first day
on Sesame Street because after we
finished recording everyone gather
around to take pictures of me and
Gabrielle and I was wondering why like
why is this so important and that kind
of made it click to me too that it was
an a historic moment and I remember
looking at her and I just smiled and I
hugged her as if she was a real person
Megan's Journey as a puppeteer began
when she was just 10 years
[Music]
old watching and studying VHS tapes of
her Puppeteer and ventriloquist Idol
Sher Lewis that's how I feel right and
don't you forget it right right all
right and as a shy young Megan developed
her craft it filled her with new
confidence puppetry helped me find my
voice I lived deep inside of a a shell I
was afraid to express myself and afraid
to share the creative ideas that I had
so once I found puppetry eventually I
felt comfortable speaking on my own and
singing on my own when I grow up Megan
now shares that confidence with millions
of kids who tune in to watch broadcast
in over 150 countries Sesame Street has
been educating and supporting children
for more than five decades I knew the
importance of that character and the
impact that she would have on girls of
color around the world because she's not
just a black American Girl She
represents children of color Megan and
Gabrielle help children to learn have
fun and to understand profound social
issues my very first opportunity with
Sesame Street was breaking down racism
for kids breaking down the June 2020
George Floyd protest and Gabrielle's
line I'll never forget is racism is when
someone treats you unfairly or unkindly
because of the color of your skin so
Sesame Street has the ability to take
these ginormous issues ginormous World
issues and bring them down to where a
child can understand them process them
and respond to them on the street where
so many famous characters and puppeteers
have made history with their
performances you can stand up and dance
Megan is a shining example of the future
of puppetry I see puppetry growing um
amongst the new generation and so I just
see the genre expanding
immensely
hey
you I hope my legacy is spreading hope
enjoy throughout the world simple as
[Music]
that